WORLD LEADERS OF COURSE
WILL BE DESCENDED ON LONDON TO
ATTEND THE QUEEN STATE FUNERAL.
THAT HAPPENS ON MONDAY.
AND SURPRISINGLY, THE RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN WILL
NOT BE AMONG THEM.
EXTRAORDINARY, AND NOW, TO
RECALL THE STARTLING WAS IN
POWER WHEN ELIZABETH SECOND
ATTACK SOUNDED THE THRONE.
BUT IN MOSCOW, TODAY PUTIN IS
UNDER GROWING PRESSURE, AS
UKRAINE REGAINS MORE MORE
TERRITORY IN A LIGHTNING
COUNTEROFFENSIVE.
THIS FOOTAGE SHOWS PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY VISITING THE
NEWLY-LIBERATED AREAS, SOME OF
THEM THERE IN THE EAST.
SUPPORTING THE SOLDIERS ON THE
CIVILIANS.
THESE KINDS OF VICTORIES PILING
THE PRESSURE ON PRESIDENT PUTIN
AS WE HEAR.
SO LET US TRY TO GET SOME
INSIGHT INTO HOW VLADIMIR PUTIN
WILL PROCESS HIS LOSSES, WITH
HIS FORMER SPEECH WRITER ABBAS
GALLYAMOV.
HE'S JOINING ME AND NOW.
MR., GALLYAMOV THANKS FOR COMING
TO THE PROGRAM.
IT'S ALWAYS SO INTERESTING FOR
US TO TRY TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN MOSCOW.
SO I KNOW THAT YOU ARE NOT A
MILITARY HISTORIAN OR
STRATEGIST.
BUT POLITICALLY, WHAT CAN YOU
DESCRIBE FOR US, HOW YOU THINK,
POTENTIALLY, THE POLITICAL TIDE
MAY BE SHIFTING AGAINST PUTIN
RIGHT NOW?
WHAT DO YOU SEEING FROM MOSCOW?
>> YOU MUST UNDERSTAND THAT
RUSSIAN POLITICAL SYSTEM IS A
REAL SHOCK NOW, THIS IS NO
EXAGGERATION.
FOR MANY, YEARS RUSSIANS, THE
REGIME, WAS CREATING UKRAINIANS
AS SOMETHING INFERIOR.
SO THEY COULD NEVER IMAGINE THE
UKRAINIANS --
THOSE INVINCIBLE TROOPS, HOW
THEY WERE VIEWING THEM, WOULD
HAVE TO RETRACE AND NOT JUST
RETREAT, ACTUALLY RUN AWAY.
AND THIS IS A REAL SHOCK.
LITTLE BY LITTLE, THE RUSSIANS
GOT ACQUAINTED TO THE THOUGHT,
THAT'S OKAY, UKRAINIANS ARE NOT
SO BAD AFTER ALL.
THEY CAN DEFEND THEMSELVES.
THEY CAN BE ON THE DEFENSIVE.
BUT NOBODY WOULD EXPECT THAT
THEY CAN ADVANCE SO RAPIDLY AND
SO PROFESSIONALLY.
INTO MAKING THE RUSSIANS ARE.
TREAT THE SYSTEM HAS BEEN A
SHOCK AND.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IS ABSOLUTELY
INADEQUATE REACTION TO PUTIN,
PERSONALLY.
YOU KNOW WHEN HE ISN'T SHOCK
HIMSELF HE BEHAVES --
WHEN HE DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO ACT
WHAT HE IS DOING USUALLY SHOWS
THAT NOTHING BAD IS HAPPENING.
HE DID NOT CHANGE HIS SCHEDULE
AND UNFORTUNATELY FOR HIM FOR
THIS PARTICULAR DAY, MOSCOW WAS
CELEBRATING LIKE A CITY DAY,
HOLIDAY, GREAT HOLIDAY.
TAKING PART IN FESTIVE
ACTIVITIES AND MAKING ENTIRE
WORKS, AND THAT'S WHAT
PARTICULAR MOMENTS WHEN HIS
TROOPS WERE INCLUDED.
THIS IS AN ADEQUATE, BEHAVIOR
OF COURSE.
LIKE IT REALLY IRRITATED A LOT
OF RUSSIANS.
NOT JUST.
OPPOSITION NO NOW.
NOT JUST TALKING WITH
OPPOSITION.
I'M TALKING ABOUT REGULAR
RUSSIANS.
I WOULD SAY THAT PUTIN'S IMAGE
IS TARNISHED.
>> RIGHT.
MR. GALLIUM OF, IT'S INCREDIBLE
AS YOU SAY THAT SCORES OF
DEPUTIES, ACCORDING TO HIS
RESIGNATION, AND MANY PEOPLE,
ARE NOW QUESTIONING PUBLICLY,
DID YOU GET IT WRONG YOU BADLY
ADVISED, WHAT HAPPENS?
HOW DO YOU THINK WILL REACT TO
THAT.
WILL YOU TRY TO TRICK GOOD
NEGOTIATIONS?
WILL HE ADDRESS THIS ISSUE?
WHAT WE CALL A NATIONAL DRAFT?
HOW WILL YOU REACT?
>> YOU KNOW, ALL THE OPTIONS
THAT HE HAS ARE BAD FOR ME.
--
IS IMPOSSIBLE BUT RUSSIANS ARE
NOT WILLING TO GO TO WAGE THIS
WAR.
TO TAKE PART IN THIS WAR.
THEY CAN, SUPPORT, LIKE HALF OF
RUSSIANS THEY SUPPORT.
DID YOU SUPPORT THIS WAR.
BUT THEIR SUPPORT IS PURELY
THEORETICAL.
THEY ARE NOT READY TO GO AND
SACRIFICE THEIR --
ESPECIALLY AT THE MOMENT WHEN
UKRAINIANS ARE DANCING AND
RUSSIANS ARE RETREATING.
IF THEY DID NOT WANT TO GO TO
WORK AT THE MOMENT WHEN THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BE A
QUICK BLITZKRIEG, DEFINITELY
ARE NOT GOING TO DO IT NOW.
IF PUTIN STARTS MAKING THIS
NATIONAL DRAFT, HE REALLY FACES
THE DANGER OF RIOTS.
AND ACTUALLY IT'S NOT CLEAR IF
HIS LOYAL NATIONAL GUARDS WILL
REALLY SUPPRESS THOSE RIGHTS
LIKE BEFORE.
BECAUSE NOW THOSE NATIONAL
GUARDS, THEY WERE THERE IN
UKRAINE.
AND THEY WERE BORN THERE BY
UKRAINE AND FORCEFUL UKRAINIAN
ARTILLERY.
DEFINITELY THEY ARE NO LONGER
AS LAURA AS TO PROTESTS BEFORE.
SO IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT HE GETS,
IF HE MAKES THIS NATIONAL
DRAFT.
REAL, NEW FORCES.
WHICH WILL BE FOR THE
UKRAINIANS OR RIOTS WHICH WILL
OVERTHROW HIM.
SO THIS IS A BETTER OPTION.
LIKE NEGOTIATIONS, DEFINITELY,
THEY'RE READY FOR THIS NOW.
THIS IS A PROBLEM.
ZELENSKYY REFUSES.
TO START THE NEGOTIATIONS HE
SHOULD REALLY FIND SUCCESS --
I THINK THE NEXT THING THAT HAS
HAPPENED IN RUSSIAN POLITICS
WITHIN THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS,
MAYBE UP TO HALF A YEAR, IS
THAT --
WILL START LOOKING FOR A
SUCCESSOR.
IT'S REALLY A POLITICAL PROCESS
WILL BE GETTING THE RIGHT --
THIS FIGURE.
>> ABBAS GALLYAMOV, A FORMER
SPEECH WRITER TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THOSE INSIGHTS.